well we're having a look at today is a
kind of diagram with some of you have
encountered before but perhaps not all
of you it's got a Venn diagram named
after a guy named John then and it was a
way to represent the relationships
between different groups of things now
remember we're in the topic probability
so we're going to come to the connection
between this and probability in a few
minutes but first let's have a look at
what you've got here right now before
you start fiddling you can see you've
got a series of shapes here and we can
represent these shapes according to
different groups and we can use
different rules to divide these up right
now if you have a look at the top there
you'll notice I'll just zoom in for you
you'll notice there's a few different
kinds of ways we can break up these
groups so this is where you've just got
one group and then everything that's not
in that group okay so that's a very
simple Venn diagram you know this
diagram here where the two categories
that we can choose are completely
separate so I'll give you some more
language with that in a second but have
a look for a minute if I select that
you've got your two different groups of
things and they will represent two
things that have no overlap so as an
example if I chose a rule someone pick
one of these for me please
squares okay if I pick squares yeah and
then if I have a look at my options for
my second rule over here you can see
that my list has gotten a lot shorter
did you notice that can i zoom in I
think it's going to look the same size
if I know it's not gonna let me I used
to have like lots more options here did
you notice I used to have like big and
small and like kind of thing but here
I've only got circles triangles and
hexagons because you can't be a square
square and a circle at the same time you
can't be a square in a triangle at the
same time it's that makes sense but I'd
like you all now to do you can lift your
lid back up now is I want you to select
that third one where you can see there's
an overlap here this is where we're
going to have a bit of a think now I
invite you to select any two rules for
circle one and circle two I'm going to
pick you can pick the same as me or a
different if you like I'm going to pick
hexagons for rule for circle number one
so everything in this circle I'm gonna
put my hexagons in and then on the other
side I'm gonna choose I'm gonna go we
if small so these things are all gonna
be circled sorry hexagons and these
things are all going to be small for me
anyway I will let you pick your own
rules and give you a couple of minutes
you just drag and drop shapes so this is
a shape that is neither a hexagon nor
small so it goes on the outside if I
picked a shape like this red one here
where is this one gonna go guys
this this red one here where should it
go should it go is a big or small it's
small so it's going to be in this circle
is it in the middle part or the right
part it's in the well let's just try in
the middle and see what happens if I let
go but it goes back because what is that
middle area it's it's both of them at
the same time right it'll be small and
hexagons which is not right so I'm gonna
put that in the right spot why don't you
go ahead pick your rules and then put
all the shapes in and then once you've
done that for whatever it is that you've
got can you draw that diagram into your
book whatever it is that you choose okay
so go ahead put all the shapes in the
right spots and then draw it in your
book thank you you can see what I've
done is once I've put them all in on the
screen I've now said oh okay this is
what I've got you can see I've done my
best to draw it I don't have a yellow
whiteboard marker so I used orange
hopefully you can somewhat see the
difference even though it doesn't matter
for this because I didn't choose color
as any of my rules okay now yours will
probably look a little bit different
because you may not have chosen the same
rules that I did they will probably be
working with more or less the same
shapes now how do we connect this to
probability well when we're thinking
about for example a group of different
things and maybe they're all in a bucket
and you're like I'm gonna pick one of
these shapes out right I can say what's
the probability of getting a small
circle that could be a question that I
asked right or what's the probability of
getting a big shape that could be
another question that I ask and I will
base my answers based on all of the
different arrangements of shapes here
and how many there are in each region so
here's all your to do I want to once
you've got your diagram there I want us
to sort of convey
this into something that's a little more
easy to work with numerically and then
we will answer some questions about it
okay
so underneath wait you've got your
diagram which has shapes in it okay if I
want to work out for instance the
probability of if I've got all these
shapes in a bag and I say to you I draw
one out of random what's the probability
that I pick out a large hexagon okay I
mean you can see how many large hexagons
there are and you can see there's all
these other shapes what I really need to
know is how many do I have of each how
many are favorable events how large is
that what is it called again when we
have all of the things all together
every possibility is called the sample
space very good so I just need to know
how many there are it's really the
number in each little section that's the
most important to me okay so underneath
your diagram or maybe beside I'm gonna
do mine underneath I'd like you to
redraw the then part of the Venn diagram
so you've got these circles it is
important to label them with whatever it
is your rules were chosen
I chose hexagons and small and then what
we're going to do is do a count of each
little area and how many shapes there
are in each one okay so before you have
a go at your one can you help me out
with mine how many shapes do you see
let's go on the outside in the rectangle
but not in any of the circles how many
shapes do you count are there nine nine
so I'm gonna put a nine on the outside
so this represents all the shapes that I
know the hexagons know small so it's all
the big non hexagon shapes that's the
compliment does that make sense
how many shapes in here this is a bit
easier to count three that are hexagons
but not small what about right in the
middle three small hexagons and lastly
nine okay fantastic so you may actually
have depending on the different rules
that you chose for your circles you may
have some very similar numbers to me
what we can say here is the size of the
sample space
is every single item all can sit up
together and you can do this for your
own as well
three plus three plus nine plus nine
anyone tell me Twenty twenty one twenty
this is six was twenty four I think
yeah okay I was like wait did I miss cut
before twenty four is how many I got
okay now if you actually have a look you
could hit reset once you're finished
drawing on your theme and I think what
will happen is all the shapes go over to
the left-hand side and if I remember
correctly you'll see it nicely lines up
there's three across and then I think
goes eight down three times eight
twenty-four do you have the same numbers
I do yes though same number yeah
fantastic
so now underneath this right if I said
to you what is the probability of
drawing out a large hexagon from here so
I'm gonna say P of large hexagon how
many large hexagons are there on my
diagram there are three right it's that
little region over here so that's the
top of my fraction the favorable events
three and then on the denominator for a
probability it's gonna be the whole
sample space right like I'm drawing out
of the whole bag so in this case it
would be 24 very good and you could go
further and then simplify that right let
me ask another question how about the
probability of say just a hexagon
full-stop the probability of any kind of
hexagon this is yeah it's gonna be six
is another three and the three together
so I'm gonna say that's six out of the
same 24 and again I can go forward and I
can simplify that okay now if I then say
we said large hexagon regular hexagons
this area in between right where there's
an overlap what would you call those
shapes these shapes in here on my
diagram its small hexagons yeah
so I want it to be small and a hexagon
and that's a way of saying this area
that overlaps so I'm actually going to
write that in that particular way
it's small and it's a hexagon
how many shapes small and a hexagon it's
a similar fraction to one we've already
seen right it's gonna be hold on hold on
there's three in there right
three out of the same 24 I'm not even
gonna bother simplifying that faction
you ready to get it now can you look up
for a second I just want to hit pause on
your writing because now I'm gonna make
a very small distinction you know word
anyway but actually makes a big
difference so just look up for a second
look up look up look up I want to have a
look at the same idea here but instead
of the word and I'm going to substitute
in the word or and it's a tiny tiny
difference but it makes a big sort of
distinction in how we answer this
question small or hexagon how would you
look at this diagram and tell me which
parts of it are included yeah Jessica so
the two out two circles but not the ones
in between hmm what you guys reckon
small hexagon is this shape small is it
a hexagon so is it small or hexagons so
what you're picking up on is this
ambiguity right now this phrase in
itself is kind of like the fact that
half of you reckon it's this way and a
halfie records that way sort of points
out that our language does have
limitations right I think those of you
who are saying who agree with Jessica I
say it's a hexagon or it's small but
it's not both does that make sense like
that's what you're trying to exclude I
can write this I'm gonna take this I can
write this in such a way as to make it
not ambiguous anymore I just need an
extra word right small or hexagon only
do you see that word there right it
means you can be small but not a hexagon
you can be a hexagon but not small that
would only sort of excludes out the
other option does that make sense okay
but when I go back this is how I
originally wrote it
the word only is not there right so
these shapes on the middle they all
satisfy this condition so how many
shapes are in both circles altogether 15
yeah 15 out of 24 can you help me
simplify that
what can I 5 over 5 at 8
I'll divide the top and the bottom by 3
and there you go okay and just for
completeness sake let's do that one more
underneath small or hexagons only I'm
gonna put that in capitals to really
emphasize it now if we go with Jessica's
original idea and and exclude that one
in the middle what's my favorite number
of outcomes this time it's not gonna be
15 anymore right taking out these three
so how many do I get left with twelve
twelve out of the same 24 I've been
looking at what does that simplify to
uh-huh
there we go okay now this set of
probabilities and this use of this very
careful use of language right you need
to be really cautious with right you'll
have something slightly different
because you've chosen different rules to
meet but that's fine
once you've finished I'm gonna leave you
now I'll leave all this up on the board
I love you have your version of this
diagram with just the numbers in it
that's the part that really matters to
me it helps me calculate all these
probabilities and you can jot down an
equivalent set of different things I've
got one two three four five except these
ones end up being the same so maybe I'd
like you to come up with four different
probabilities that will have different
answers at the end do you notice that
I've got this one's different to this
one which is different to this one which
is different to this one I'd like you to
come with 4 different things you can ask
of your arrangement of shapes that will
give you different probabilities each of
them okay this actually has a name I
might as well give it that name for you
guys in the context of these questions
this big box around us is called the
universal set the universal set for this
question right so this is not every
single shape that can ever exist yeah
like I don't have any trapeze
on my diagram right these guys are just
the shapes I'm considering at the moment
this is my universe as it were in which
I answer my probabilities okay so do
include that box